les touristes qui viendront cet été
visiter Besançon auront à leur
disposition un petit train tout blanc
pour découvrir la ville natale de
victorugo ce nouveau moyen de transport
qui fait très vacances partira du
parkingot traversera la ville et montera
à l'assaut de la citadelle à la vitesse
de 25 km/h fabriqué en France ce petit
train résoudra aussi le problème de
l'accès de la citadelle par l'écart de
tourisme les trois vagonnés de ce petit
train peuvent transporter 55 adultes
pour 75 enfants si vous voulez monter
vers la citadelle sans vous essouffler
il vous en coûtera 20 francs entrer à la
citadelle comprise les départs ont lieu
tous les jours à partir de demain à 11h
mais dès le mois de juin le service du
Pin est assuré de 9h à
19h le trajet dure 40 minutes et la
visite est commmentcé ce petit tuptub
silencieux aura un seul mérite celui de
nous transporter dans un autre univers
même les
de